[Musik]
herr bundeskanzler scholz zerstören sie
diese mauer geben sie deutschland die
führungsrolle die es verdient damit ihre
nachfahren stolz auf sie sind
unterstützen sie den frieden
unterstützen sie die ukraine stoppen sie
diesen krieg helfen sie uns diesen krieg
zu beenden
so mahnt der ukrainische präsident
selensky in seiner emotionalen
videoansprache im bundestag und erntete
dafür stehende ovationen anschließend
aber holt die abgeordneten die
wirklichkeit in deutschland wieder ein
debatten über die einführung einer
allgemeinen impfpflicht und die
diskussion über corona schutzmaßnahmen
am nachmittag auch thema im kanzleramt
in der konferenz der 16
ministerpräsidentinnen und präsidenten
mit bundeskanzler schulz
ja wir gehen ins dritte corona und in
die vierte kriegswoche zerstörung tod
und vertreibung auf der einen und auf
der anderen seite eine pandemie die
trotz impfkampagne andauert wir kommen
zu diesem zdf spezial die politik steht
in diesen tagen ja vor zwei aufgaben so
riesig dass sie sonst ein ganzes
jahrzehnt beschäftigen würden aber
politik kann sich ihre krisen nicht
aussuchen und so müssen bund und länder
herausforderungen meistern die sich auch
in zahlen messen lassen täglich fast
300.000 neuinfektionen hier fast 190.000
nach deutschland gekommene
kriegsflüchtlinge dort und zu
verschiedenen diese dinge auch sind sie
führen an belastungsgrenzen bevor wir
mit franziska giffey darüber sprechen
fast david gebhard den tag zusammen
es sollte der tag der solidarität mit
der ukraine werden des zusammenrücken
der demokraten doch es wurde auch der
tag an dem das taktgefühl abhanden kam
im parlament die union will eine debatte
zur ukraine durchsetzen die ampel nicht
zank über die tagesordnung da war die
rede des ehrengasts aus dem kriegsgebiet
kaum verhallt man muss sich da auch
überlegen wie das eigentlich auf die
leute dort wirkt deren leben ist in
gefahr
und zwar heute morgen und für die
nächsten zehn jahre und wir und dann
anfang mit spitzfindigkeiten danach zu
diskutieren finde ich das nicht
angemessen dass in einer solchen
situation nach der rede des ukrainischen
präsidenten die mehrheit stuhr
verweigert hat darüber zu reden und die
regierung verweigert hat herr
rechenschaft abzulegen das war der
würdeloses moment des parlamentes den
hilfen über 27 jahren erlebte aber heute
zuvor hatte der ukrainische präsident zu
den abgeordneten gesprochen dank für die
unterstützung aus deutschland doch auch
eine ohrfeige für die regierung die habe
etwa bei sanktionen zu spät zu wenig
getan für sein land warum ist es möglich
wir haben uns an euch gewendet wir haben
gesagt diese nord stream projekte das
ist eine art vorbereitung auf den krieg
und dann haben wir die antwort vernommen
es ist rein wirtschaftlich es ist
wirtschaft wirtschaft wirtschaft
der ukrainische präsident appelliert an
kanzler scholz direkt eine führungsrolle
einzunehmen an deutschland die
historische verantwortung des nie wieder
in die tat umzusetzen und redet den
abgeordneten ins gewissen wir haben bis
zum schluss auf diplomatie gesetzt
das war sicher richtig aber im
nachhinein
hat die ukraine mit ihren warnungen
recht behalten es ist nicht leicht
gedanklich umzuschalten von der ukraine
zum zweiten mega thema des tages corona
impfpflicht debatte habe versucht
irgendwie eine brücke zu schlagen die
vorsorge die man in anderen krisen
vernachlässigt habe sei doch ein
argument für die impfpflicht tun wir
alles um vorsorge zu treffen die
vorsorge frage ist die frage wie wir mit
den krisen umgehen und vorsorge bedeutet
denken in die virtualität in moskau
alles noch passieren es ist eine erste
debatte entschieden wird nichts
gruppenanträge werden diskutiert über
parteigrenzen hinweg
wenn wir aber nur die wahl haben
zwischen einer ständigen beschränkung
und lockt darum gefahr und der
impfpflicht dann sollten wir uns für die
impfpflicht entscheiden titel
hunderttausende ordnungsämter brauchen
wir dann eigentlich um das durchzusetzen
ein gesetz dass man nicht durchsetzen
kann darf man auch nicht beschließen
frank schaefer am nachmittag zurück von
corona zur ukraine und den auswirkungen
für deutschland etwa die unterbringung
von geflüchteten
megathemen heute im akkord jetzt sitzen
wir sozusagen mit beiden beinen mitten
drin und müssen wirklich mit einem
wahnsinns tempo versuchen
umzudrehen
zeitenwenden bei der arbeit auch schräg
gegenüber im kanzleramt bei der mpk war
es der tag der großen themen der tag der
harmonie war es nicht aber
unstrittig einhäuser ist ereignisreicher
tag auch für die regierende
bürgermeisterin und stellvertretende
npd-vorsitzende franziska gefahr guten
abend
in berlin kommen jeden tag im moment
rund 10.000 geflüchtete aus der ukraine
an ist denn ihr hilferuf folgen heute
erhört worden wir sind ja ganz klar mit
der aussage in dieser mpk gegangen dass
das das bestimmende thema auch sein muss
neben den fragen der pandemie wir haben
organisatorische personelle und auch
finanzielle unterstützung eingefordert
es gab heute ein sehr sehr klares
commitment wir haben einen zehnseitigen
beschluss gefasst über die
herausforderungen vor denen wir stehen
und der bund hat zugesichert sich hier
seiner mitverantwortung bewusst zu sein
und auch mit verantwortung übernehmen zu
wollen es ist entschieden worden dass es
eine sehr hochkarätig besetzte
arbeitsgruppe geben wird berlin wird
daran auch mit arbeiten für die
grundsätzliche klärung aller
finanzierungsfragen und ein
gesamtkonzept das eben auf integration
setzt auf perspektiven für arbeit auf
unterstützung der menschen und auf auch
unterstützung der kommunen und der
länder bei den kosten der unterbringung
und bei allen kosten die wir jetzt für
die hilfe brauchen der bundeskanzler hat
ja vorhin diese arbeitsgruppe von der
sie gesprochen haben angekündigte bis
zur siebten april soll die vorschläge
für die finanzielle teilungen vorlegen
das kann dauern bis sie da geld vom bund
sehen naja es ist ganz klar dass ja
jetzt auch schon ausgaben entstehen da
wird es darum gehen wie die zumindest
zum teil vom bund übernommen werden
können wir bekommen auch einige
unterstützung ja schon jetzt es ist ganz
klar dass der königsteiner schlüssel
angewandt werden muss der bund auch in
die koordinierte verteilung einsteigt
schon in dieser woche eingestiegen ist
das muss jetzt auch weiter so gehen es
geht zunächst einmal darum dass es eine
gute verteilung gibt unter den
bundesländern wir erhalten zb auch
unterstützung durch das bundesamt für
migration und flüchtlinge auch dass
durch das technische hilfswerk durch das
drk und heute haben wir auch die
nachricht bekommen dass wir auch
unterstützung von der bundeswehr
bekommen das sind gute schritte aber es
muss natürlich auch weitergehen es geht
um die integrationsfragen auch um
hilfeleistung und ich würde es ehrlich
gesagt lieber sehen die leute sind in
den jobcentern und werden dort betreut
als in den sozialämtern wenn es muss
darum gehen echte arbeitsperspektiven
gesundheitsversorgung und auch
leistungen für integration und
spracherwerb zu liefern und darum wird
es gehen in den kommenden wochen den
königsteiner schlüssel wenn man noch
erklären aber länder und kommunen
dringen ja auch auf eine bessere
koordinierung also eine unkompliziertere
registrierung der ankommenden daran
hapert ist ja im moment gewaltig wie
läuft das künftig besser also es ist
ganz klar dass alle die an kommen
registriert werden müssen und dafür
braucht es elektronische erfassung der
menschen es braucht auch die
erkennungsdienstlichen aufnahmen der
menschen so dass wir hier in berlin zum
beispiel ja ein großes einkaufszentrum
ukraine im ehemaligen flughafen tegel
errichten das wird am wochenende an den
start gehen wir richten uns darauf ein
dass wir zehn bis fünfzehntausend
menschen am tag hier abfertigen werden
die dann eben teilweise in berliner
unterkünfte gebracht werden aber eben
auch viele in bussen in andere
bundesländer gebracht werden bei dieser
koordinierungs und registrierungs
leistung brauchen wir die unterstützung
vom bund zum beispiel durch die
elektronischen registrierung stationen
die nur das bamf entsprechend geben kann
da werden wir jetzt auch staaten mit
aber die zahlen werden weiter steigen
und dann braucht es auch weitere
unterstützung und das was wir jetzt
sehen ist ein anfang einer entwicklung
wir gehen davon aus dass die zahlen noch
viel größer werden und das auch in
anderen bundesländern eine ähnliche
situation eintreten wird wie hier in
berlin wir bringen ja im moment am tag
über 1000 menschen in unseren
landeseigenen unterbringungs kapazitäten
unter und da muss man schon sagen das
bringt einen kapazitätsgrenzen und siehe
da so kommt der gute alte flughafen
tegel doch noch zu späten ehren danke
und größer und ich spreche sehr gern ja
was auch immer bund länder und gemeinden
tun oben geflüchteten ein neues zuhause
zu ermöglichen ohne private initiative
wird es nicht gehen das beginnt im
eigenen bereich das beginnt im
sprachgebrauch geht weiter mit der
großherzigen spende und manch einer legt
sich sogar persönlich ins zeug sammelt
transportiert organisiert hilfe im
freundes kollegen oder kommilitonen
kreis hier drei vorbilder aus dresden
gießen und bremen
sowie 8 uhr 15 die schülerin dana aus
kiew lernt mit unterstützung ihrer
lehrerin ihre ersten wörter deutsch für
die neunjährige ein neuanfang umso
wichtiger dass ihr bruder im selben
vorkurs sitzt obwohl die beiden erst vor
acht tagen mit ihrer mutter in
deutschland angekommen sind wurden sie
an dieser bremer oberschule sofort
aufgenommen ohne bürokratische hürden
alles sehr spontan und doch ein stück
stabilität
in der ukraine hatte ich angst
hier fühle ich mich sicher
als sich an diese schule kam habe ich
gemerkt hier ist alles okay die lehrer
sind nett die mitschüler auch
ich fühle mich hier in sicherheit
in sicherheit an einer schule in der
integration seit langem alltag ist
mitten im hochhausviertel gelegen werden
hier 35 nationalitäten unterrichtet
kinder aus ländern wie kenia afghanistan
und jetzt aus der ukraine schüler mit
bewegten lebens geschichten und teils
traumatischen erfahrungen
das wichtigste im moment beim ankommen
jetzt ist auf jeden fall die sicherheit
und das
schaffen wir auf jeden fall indem wir
ihnen einen ort schaffen indem sie
andere kinder kennenlernen können manche
können sich besser durch lernen ablenken
manche durchspielen doch dana lässt sich
nicht so leicht ablenken sie ist traurig
wenn sie an die ukraine denkt an ihren
vater die wohnung und ihre katze so
vieles hat sie dort zurückgelassen
deuce meine größte angst ist dass ich
nie wieder nach hause zurück kann so
fühlt sich auch ihr bruder nasa umso
wichtiger dass sie an dieser schule halt
und erste freunde gefunden haben
machen wir alles was die lieferung von
medizinischem material in die ukraine
ist lubomir littwin schock ein
herzensanliegen immer mehr verletzte
werden dort in die krankenhäuser
eingeliefert der ukrainische augenarzt
arbeitet seit sechs jahren im
uniklinikum gießen sicherlich ist die
nachlieferung von materialen sehr
erschwert in diesen zeiten und ich
müssen wir unterstützen das ist unsere
ziel dass zum beispiel mario pohl
kinderkrankenhäuser angegriffen werden
was sagen sie als arzt dazu
sprachlos bin sportlich
infusionspumpen momenten geräte oder op
tische nur mit windschott weiß was die
krankenhäuser in seinem heimatland am
meisten benötigen
auch antonia sachsen was man isst
augenarzt deswegen kennt die familie lu
bo mit windschutz zwei nächte hatten sie
sich im keller ihres hauses verschanzt
als in der nähe die bomben fielen bis
sie ohne den vater und ehemann flohen
es ist sehr schlimm für mich dass mein
vater in der ukraine geblieben ist ich
mache mir große sorgen es tut sehr weh
logo mit windschott lässt sich
regelmäßig von seinen kollegen in der
ukraine über die aktuelle situation
informieren ihre berichte aus kiew
lemberg oder besser werden immer
dramatischer
ich habe gestern einen jungen mann
operiert er hat sein auge verloren
nachdem in seiner nähe eine bombe
titulierte
wir leben jeden tag raketeneinschläge
bomben wir bekommen patienten aus der
gesamten ukraine
und dann erzählen sie von frühgeborenen
in einer klinik die von den russen
bombardiert wurde sie haben einfach die
zettel drauf auf die babys geklebt wer
gehört über das fenster haben sie die
babys übergeben und gerettet das
verstehen sie das ist unfassbar
der schock sitzt tief aber lubomir
litwinschuh castro dass er seinen
landsleuten von hier aus helfen kann
bis vor kurzem war tanja biglia war
selbst noch auf der flucht aus kiew nun
hier in dresden wirft sie sich in die
flüchtlingsarbeit als übersetzerin bei
der lernwerkstatt eine anlaufstelle für
ukrainische eltern und kinder die hier
beschäftigung finden sie sind kreativ
und so fühlen sich kinder ein bisschen
entspannt ja das ist sehr wichtig und
sehr wichtige sie aus struktur haben sie
müssen um 10 uhr hier seien ja um 12
können sie nach hause gehen und das
macht sie ein bisschen mehr sicher anke
lange von der tu dresden hatte das
projekt mit aus dem boden gestampft
studierende angeschrieben unterstützer
gesucht wir sind eines dieser angebote
um den kindern einmal am tag für zwei
stunden bzw einmal kochen wir auch
zusammen dann für vier stunden einfach
täglichen angebot anzubieten auf den
aufruf der uni hatten sich dutzende
studierende gemeldet haben seminare
verlegt oder abgabetermine für
hausarbeiten verschoben immer schließen
sie bei den lehrkräften auf verständnis
ein projekt das sich lohnt auch für
helfer und helferinnen ich glaube gerade
diese kleinen situation wo man sich mit
händen und füßen verständigt und am ende
alle lachen da rausgehen weil das zeigt
einfach dass dort keine grenzen gegeben
sondern es ist ein angebot für die
kinder zum reden spielen malen und sich
sicher fühlt vom krieg reden die kinder
kaum und er wird von den helfern auch
nicht zum thema gemacht die flucht aus
der heimat aber ist allgegenwärtig
ich denke das stimmt die meisten traurig
auch wenn es aufregend sein kann
woanders zu sein aber da sie wissen sie
kommen nicht unbedingt zurück und wohin
sie zurückkommen es ähnlich das was es
mal war merkt man schon dass sie sehr
traurig sind erstmals sind die kinder
aber hier und keiner weiß wie lange
vielleicht wird dresden ja für einige
auch eine neue heimat eine heimat die
dann hier in der lernwerkstatt ihren
ursprung fand
[Musik]
ja stichwort heimat rund drei millionen
menschen haben ihr heimatland die
ukraine bisher verlassen der
migrationsforscher gerald knaus geht von
bis zu 10.000.000 aus die es noch werden
könnten guten abend nach hamburg
guten abend genauso wenn sie recht
behalten wäre das ja die größte
fluchtbewegungen seit dem zweiten
weltkrieg wie kommen sie auf diese
düstere prognose
ja ich hoffe natürlich dass ich nicht
recht behalte aber die entwicklung der
letzten drei wochen hat uns gezeigt dass
jede woche eine million menschen aus der
ukraine in die europäische union und
nach moldawien geflohen sind eine
million pro woche wenn das so weitergeht
bis ende märz dann sind wir bereits in
zwei wochen bei 5 millionen und der
krieg in der ukraine verschärft sicher
und verursacht immer mehr gründe für
menschen aus den städten des landes zu
fliehen angesichts dessen ist die
hilfsbereitschaft in deutschland ja
gewaltig muss man sagen die europäische
union hat sich auf 1 rechte
unbürokratisches anerkennungsverfahren
geeinigt wo sehen sie
verbesserungsbedarf
also diese welle der empathie die
aufnahmebereitschaft in den ärmsten
ländern wie moldawien aber auch in polen
oder deutschland ist enorm aber das ist
erst der anfang
wenn in den nächsten zwei wochen zwei
millionen menschen kommen die werden
nicht den polen untergebracht werden
können in warschau sind jetzt schon
300.000 menschen um das einzuordnen das
wäre so als müsste berlin jetzt 600.000
menschen aufnehmen und das bedeutet dass
die die jetzt kommen weiter ziehen
werden und das muss man organisieren
also wir brauchen jetzt dringend eine
eine luftbrücke die etwa menschen aus
moldawien nach spanien nach
großbritannien nach frankreich bringt
und daran muss man jetzt arbeiten sonst
werden diese zwei millionen alle nach
deutschland oder österreich kommen also
der großen das heißt es genügt ihrer
meinung nach nicht wenn die
bundesregierung wie jetzt geplant ein
paar busse nach moldawien schickt und
ein paar tausend flüchtlinge
gewissermaßen übernimmt
also die luftbrücke die es jetzt gibt
für moldawien betrifft 7000 personen
wenn aber der kampf um besser wir
fürchten müssen bald entbrennt dann
werden wir uns auf einige hunderttausend
einstellen müssen die nach moldawien
kommen das land ist das ärmste land
europas hat 2,5 millionen einwohner und
derzeit schon 100.000 menschen
aufgenommen also die werden weiterziehen
und da braucht man dann eine ganz andere
organisation und schon jetzt hat europa
mehr menschen aufgenommen als im sommer
2015 auf ein verbindliches verteilsystem
haben sich die eu staaten bisher nicht
einigen können wird es so etwas
vielleicht diesmal brauchen vielleicht
sogar mit zwang
das wird nicht funktionieren und das
wäre eine illusion darauf zu setzen aber
was funktionieren könnte wäre jetzt
politisch einen koordinator eine
koordinatorin zu benennen die jetzt an
die empathie appelliert die es ja auch
in anderen ländern gibt in
großbritannien haben sich neben einem
tag 80 tausend menschen gemeldet und
gesagt sie würden ukrainerinnen
aufnehmen und ihre kinder in spanien in
portugal überall gibt es empathie aber
man muss es organisieren man müsste
jetzt
klarmachen dass in den nächsten zwei
wochen eben nicht nur zwei millionen
menschen ankommen sondern auch einige
hunderttausend nach frankreich spanien
portugal irland gebracht werden und dann
müsste man in diesen ländern natürlich
die aufnahme organisieren das wäre ein
zeichen dass europa hier anders als 2015
gemeinsam agiert dafür müsste man werben
das müsste man organisieren aber jeder
tag zählt und derzeit gibt es diese
struktur nicht und in brüssel wurde mir
heute wieder gesagt hat man das gefühl
man muss da nicht sehr viel machen die
leute werden sich von selbst verteilen
und ich halte das für eine illusion so
der appell der migrationsforscher als
gerald knaus heute abend übrigens auch
zu gast bei markus lanz im zdf vielen
dank nach hamburg
ich danke ihnen
ja eine verbindliche verteilung dass es
nicht nur eine europäische
herausforderung das auch aber sie muss
zunächst hier im land bestanden werden
wie gelingt es die lasten der
flüchtlings versorgung und unterbringung
gerecht zu verteilen die antwort liefert
der sogenannten königsteiner schlüssel
sie sind gestrandet am berliner
hauptbahnhof wie hier kommen bundesweit
täglich tausende geflüchtete aus der
ukraine an fast 100 88.000 wurden bisher
registriert
doch wohin nach dem ersten aufwärmen
nicht alle kommen privat unter unter
lokal überlastungen droht sollen die
menschen nun verteilt werden und zwar
nach dem königsteiner schlüssel dieser
weist allen bundesländern einen anteil
der erfassten geflüchteten zu die quote
basiert zu zwei dritteln auf dem
steueraufkommen der länder und zu einem
drittel auf ihrer einwohnerzahl und wird
jährlich aktualisiert
derzeit soll demnach nrw mit 21 prozent
den größten anteil der ankömmlinge
aufnehmen gefolgt von bayern mit rund 15
einheit prozent das saarland und bremen
müssen um die ein prozent der menschen
unterbringen der bund kann sich
finanziell beteiligen
doch der schlüssel ist umstritten die
kritik schon 2015 als menschen aus
syrien und irak hier her flohen er
berücksichtige private kontakte sowie
lokale kapazitäten auf wohn und
arbeitsmarkt oder in bildungsstätten zu
wenig
unklar ist auch ob die angedachte
verteilung überhaupt funktioniert denn
menschen aus der ukraine genießen
visafreiheit dürfen sich also 90 tage
lang eu-weit frei bewegen so lange
müssen sie sich nicht registrieren weit
mehr als die 188 1000 flüchtlinge
dürften somit in deutschland seien teils
um fast
nach fragen dazu an den bayerischen
innenminister und vorsitzenden der
innenministerkonferenz joachim herrmann
kurs konnten auch gleich das garten
gehören sie im moment nicht ich versuche
trotzdem mal die frage zu stellen der
königsteiner schlüssel wie eben
beschrieben schon über 70 jahre alt
taugt er jetzt auch zur verteilung der
flüchtlinge aus der ukraine
sonst
der ton ist nicht so optimal versuchen
wir es noch mal
ja noch mal die frage taugt der
königsteiner schlüssel auch für die
verteilung der flüchtlinge aus der
ukraine
ja für die verteilung innerhalb
deutschlands absoluten
in einigen ländern scheinen die behörden
ja schon jetzt überfordert von der zahl
der neuankömmlinge in hamburg zum
beispiel müssen frauen und kinder auf
stundenlang in der kälte warten bis sie
sich registrieren lassen können wie
lässt sich denn da kurzfristig gegen
steuern
vornehmen wir haben heute wieder
eigentlich ist
wir müssen schon heute
lassen das muss doch besser gesteuert
werden aber
das tut uns sehr leid der tod ist leider
sehr schlecht vor allem die
hintergrundgeräusche sind so laut dass
wir sie kaum verstehen könnte deswegen
müssen wir dieses gespräch hat dieser
stelle beenden was mir sehr leid tut
aber danke und viele grüße nach
berchtesgaden
ja 22 tage krieg in europa und was ist
mit der hoffnung auf frieden auch die
bekommt beständig nahrung der
ukrainische präsident erklärt vernehme
positive signale aus moskau und auch im
kreml ist von fortschritten in den
verhandlungen die rede aber im brutalen
widerspruch zur politischen annäherung
steht das kriegsgeschehen selbst vor
allem im osten und im süden der ukraine
sprechen ausschließlich die waffen
sie dachten hier wären sie geschützt in
diesem theater in mario pohl hatten in
den letzten tagen mehr als 1000 menschen
unter ihnen viele kinder zuflucht
gesucht
dann fielen gestern bomben noch immer
versuchen rettungskräfte verletzte zu
finden es heißt tote mussten sie bislang
noch nicht bergen der luftschutzkeller
soll standgehalten haben seit über zwei
wochen ist mario pohl von der russischen
armee eingekesselt die lage katastrophal
kein wasser kein strom keine heizung
immer wieder versuchen die behörden
flucht korridor einzurichten
diese autokolonne mit etwa 1500 menschen
schaffte es bis nach afrika manche sind
bis unters dach vollgepackt manche mit
bis zu sieben personen besetzt manche
ohne fensterscheiben die druckwelle
einer bombe sagt er
es war so unheimlich besonders wenn die
bomben abgeworfen haben wir haben im
keller geschlafen unser haus wurde von
einer bombe getroffen es ist komplett
abgebrannt und diese frau sagt die
leichen liegen in den straßen es ist die
hölle wenn die hölle das tier dann dort
erst mal sind sie in sicherheit aber das
grauen sitzt in ihren köpfen die
hauptstadt kiew leidet mit seinen
menschen immer mehr 16 stockwerke hatte
dieses hochhaus bis es am morgen von
trümmerteilen eine abgeschossenen rakete
getroffen wurde mindestens ein mensch
starb und viele verletzt wurden 30
bewohner konnten die feuerwehrmänner
allein aus den oberen etagen retten und
den brand schnell löschen
die bilder aber werden sich ihnen für
immer ein brennen
auch aktiv im nordosten bekommt keine
atempause wird weiter schwer bombardiert
nur noch grippe bleiben von diesem markt
übrig mindestens drei menschen verlieren
in dem inferno ihr leben und wieder
treffen die russischen bomben auch hier
wohnhäuser zerstören existenzen lassen
die verzweiflung wachsen davon
einschüchtern lassen sich eltern und
lehrer dieser schule nicht sie räumen
auf sie bauen wieder auf mit taten gegen
den schrecken wir packen jetzt an wir
haben von dieser katastrophe hier gehört
ich weiß nicht was ich dazu sagen soll
ist es einfach unmenschlich
sie haben fest vor ihre kinder hier am
ersten september wieder zu unterrichten
ein plan der ihnen hilft den krieg zu
ertragen
das kriegsgeschehen und die lage der
zivilbevölkerung beides steht ja in
enger verbindung zueinander und so
müssen wir auch über die militärische
lage heute ab und sprechen das tun wir
mit ex general carsten jacobson ich
grüße sie
schönen guten abend wenn wir mal mit
einer kurzen zwischenbilanz beginnen
hätten sie am 24 februar am tag der in
version geglaubt dass drei wochen später
im grunde genommen ein militärisches
patt entstanden ist
nun ich glaube als wir alle am 24
februar
aufgewacht sind in einer wie der kanzler
so richtig ausgedrückt hat veränderten
welt da haben wir alle nicht gewusst was
uns nun bevorsteht und was nun kommt die
größte fehleinschätzung hat wohl putin
in diesen tagen und stunden erlebt und
bis zum heutigen tag weil ich glaube
dass er tatsächlich gedacht hat er würde
in einem raschen schnellen chirurgische
schnitt die ukraine besetzen und den
krieg so unblutig wie möglich zu beenden
er hat nicht damit gerechnet wie stark
der friedens wille und der
freiheitswille der ukrainer ist und wie
sehr sie sich darauf gesetzt haben ihr
land zu verteidigen gegen die invasoren
und das muss er nun erkennen und
dementsprechend erleben wir das was wir
heute erleben und jetzt scheidende der
ukrainischen streitkräfte sogar offenbar
zumindest zugegen offensiven anzusetzen
das behauptet jedenfalls kiew wenn das
stimmt welche bedeutung hätte das für
den weiteren kriegsverlauf
nun das muss man zunächst einmal sehen
ich habe diese meldungen natürlich auch
gehört inwiefern sich das tatsächlich
schon auswirkt wird man sehen aber es
kennzeichnet den willen der ukrainer
diesen krieg durch zu kämpfen und ihn zu
gewinnen und damit ist die moralische
kraft der ukraine deutlich stärker das
haben wir in den ganzen letzten tagen
gesehen als die der russischen soldaten
und dementsprechend hat sich das ganze
nun mit sicherheit schon wesentlich
länger hingezogen als putin und seine
generale erwartet hatten und ungeachtet
der kampfhandlungen laufen politische
verhandlungen zwischen russland und der
ukraine es geht offenbar um mögliche
sicherheitsgarantien für die ukraine
präsident talents gefordert echten
schutz wie er sagt kann es denn ohne
eine perspektivische nato-mitgliedschaft
überhaupt geben
präsident selensky hat ja selber schon
in den letzten tagen gesagt dass er
nicht an einen beitritt in die nato
glaubt und bei der lage in der die
ukraine sich befindet steht dass
zumindest mit sicherheit in der nächsten
zeit überhaupt nicht auf der
tagesordnung für anderen seite haben die
ukrainer natürlich erlebt was es
bedeutet als die sicherheitsgarantien
bekommen haben für gegen den abzug ihrer
nuklearwaffen was mit sicherheit heute
einige ukrainer bereuen und das
sicherheitsgarantien nur dann etwas wert
sind wenn diejenigen die sie aussprechen
sich auch daran halten deswegen ist es
verständlich dass die ukraine hier jetzt
sehr misstrauisch sind sein werden und
dass er genau beobachten werden die
analyse von generalleutnant ag carsten
jacobson vielen dank für diese auskünfte
nach münster
gerne
ja polen und andere osteuropäer fordern
rasche eu beitrittsgespräche mit kiel
was im westen des kontinents also bei
den langjährigen mitgliedern für einiges
kopfschütteln sorgt für die osteuropäer
aber wäre das ein folgerichtiger schritt
nicht nur um die ukraine zu unterstützen
auch um sich selbst vor einem russland
zu schützen dass sie als wachsende
bedrohung wahrnehmen der russische
raketen beschuss eines
militärstützpunktes am sonntag und das
nur wenige kilometer von der polnischen
grenze entfernt gilt vielen polen als
schlagender beweis
wir sind am grenzübergang madita hier wo
in endet kommentar und nacht flüchtlinge
aus der ukraine an zu fuß erschöpft aber
glücklich in sicherheit zu sein
heute morgen als wir los sind haben die
fenster und türen gewackelt das macht
mir alles so eine angst deshalb bin ich
glücklich jetzt in sicherheit zu sein
[Musik]
die hilfsbereitschaft der polen ist auch
am 22 tag der russischen invasion
ungebrochen sie helfen obwohl der krieg
immer näher rückt unterdrücken damit
auch die eigene angst wir fahren weiter
entlang der grenze zwischen krieg und
frieden in einem provisorischen
flüchtlingslager treffen wie robert er
zeigt uns ein video es soll den angriff
auf die ukrainische militärbasis ja
worauf zeigen 30 russische raketen die
einschläge auch in polen zu sehen die
angst ist greifbar
russland ist weit weg von uns bei
fehlgeleiteten raketen wurden schon oft
aus versehen zivil gebäude getroffen
glauben sie nicht dass es nicht auch
möglich ist dass raketen bei uns in
polen fallen das kann passieren jeder
zeit
wie nah der krieg ist sie zwar um ihr
leben jeden tag er betreibt im
grenzgebiet vier läden für militärische
ausrüstung
seit kriegsbeginn verkauft ihr gut
robuste schuhe größe 42 bis 46 alles weg
ukrainische männer die bislang in polen
lebten kommen her decken sich ein mit
helmen westen brillen ziehen von hier
direkt in den krieg
wir haben alle angst dass sich der
konflikt ausbreitet wir wissen nicht wie
groß das alles wird wenn größeres
passiert dann sind alle unsere träume
kaputt ich schaue schon gar kein
fernsehen mehr
die ukrainischen frauen kinder und
männer können dem krieg nicht
durchwechselten entfliehen für sie ist
der grausame realität jeden tag aufs
neue seit 22 tagen
und wenn sie den menschen in der ukraine
oder auf der flucht helfen wollen dann
spenden sie bitte an das aktionsbündnis
katastrophenhilfe
stichwort zdf nothilfe ukraine die iban
nummer lautet de 65 100 400 600
104 106 100 alle informationen auch
unter spenden zdf de oder im zdf text
auf seite 8 190
wer in diesen tagen überhaupt noch einen
blick für corona hat der sieht lila auf
der karte des robert koch instituts
liegt die incidents einheiten bei über
1.000 tendenz steigend die stimmung sei
besser als die lage im land mahnt
gesundheitsminister lauterbach ob die
bundesregierung der lage gerecht wird
das werden wegen da ich selber fragen
die geplanten lockerungen die sind
jedenfalls erst durch die impfkampagne
möglich geworden und die wird nun auch
auf ukrainische flüchtlinge ausgeweitet
in der ukraine sagt julia das heißt ihr
mutterschutz gewesen war viel zu hause
eine corona impfung gilt sie daher nicht
für notwendig doch heute ist sie zur
impfaktion im unterfränkischen gemünden
gekommen sie ist jetzt weit weg von
daheim das sei die angst vor krankheit
größere die impfung für julia auch eine
voraussetzung für integration
ich hoffe dass mein kind später in den
kindergarten gehen kann dann ist es auch
ein schutz für mein kind und für die
anderen kinder
nur knapp 35 prozent der ukraine sind
doppelt geimpft der nachholbedarf bei
geflüchteten ist groß das soll es an der
kommunikation nicht scheitern
muss ich jetzt gelernt weil ich vor 40
jahren war russisch hatte aber seitdem
er nichts mehr gesprochen habe das ist
für die leute auch dann so ein bisschen
vertrauen haben sie schon mal so eine
kleine barriere hintersee die gesundheit
von geflüchteten sicherstellen da geht
es nicht nur um corona auch tuberkulose
checks wie hier im landkreis starnberg
sind wichtig für geflüchtete die in
gemeinschaftsunterkünften untergebracht
werden ist die untersuchung
verpflichtend
[Musik]
50 geflüchtete haben sie hier untersucht
ein dringender verdacht hat sich nicht
ergeben
zurück in gemünden die impfung kann nur
ein erstes angebot seien für die
geflüchteten sie sind dem krieg
entkommen aber sie haben auch noch viele
herausforderungen vor sich wissen die
ärzte hier die meisten sind natürlich
achtbar froh dass sie hier in sicherheit
sind dass sie was zu essen haben das zu
trinken haben und dass sie merken hier
gibt es menschen die kümmern sich jetzt
in mich und das ist für die alle das
allerwichtigste
da aber die psychosoziale probleme die
kommen natürlich das ist ja klar und so
wird auch psychologische betreuung nötig
sein weil das trauma bei vielen
geflüchteten tief sitzt
nur jeder dritte ukraine komplett gegen
kuwait 19 geimpft demgegenüber wirken
die 75 prozent bei uns in deutschland ja
fast wie eine erfolg und doch sind auch
die zu wenig um die hochansteckende
omikron variante aufzuhalten auch
deshalb gilt seit gestern die
berufsbezogene impfpflicht ob die
allgemeine noch beschlossen wird unklar
morgen wollen bundestag und bundesrat
erst mal das neue
infektionsschutzgesetz beschließen heute
auch thema bei den ministerpräsidenten
sebastian eben mit fakten und zahlen
die korona zahlen sind so hoch wie nie
das robert koch institut meldet heute
294 1931 neuinfektionen auch die sieben
tage ins ident steigt immer weiter heute
liegt sie bei
1651 vor genau einem jahr schienen
solche zahlen noch in weiter ferne
am 17 32 01 21 gab es 13 1435
neuansteckungen und die sieben tage
incident war bei 92 zu beginn der
pandemie vor zwei jahren gab es
1144 neuinfektionen und eine sieben tage
incidents von 7
das rk ii meldet heute
278 todesfälle an oder mit corona das
sind deutlich weniger als zum höhepunkt
der zweiten bälle am 14 januar 2021
wurden
1244 todesfälle gemeldet
doch omikron und seine subtypen scheinen
die intensivbetten weniger stark
auszulasten als die delta variante
obwohl die infektionszahlen und die
inzidenz in die höhe gehen steigt die
zahl der korona intensivpatienten nicht
so stark an wie in den wellen davor
die gemeldete hospitalisierung rate
liegt heute bei 7,58 und damit unter dem
grenzwert 9 expertinnen und experten
gehen aber wegen nach meldungen von
deutlich höheren werten aus hinzu kommen
noch viele krankmeldungen unter dem
krankenhauspersonal
trotz der steigenden zahlen will die
ampel regierung ein neues
infektionsschutzgesetz auf den weg
bringen geplant ist dass ab diesem
sonntag die bisher geltenden corona
schutzmaßnahmen weitgehend auslaufen
nach einer übergangsfrist von zwei
wochen dürfen die länder maßnahmen dann
nur noch eingeschränkt verhängen die
masken pflicht könnte dann nur noch in
krankenhäusern pflegeeinrichtungen und
im personennahverkehr gelten weitere
maßnahmen könnten dann eingeführt werden
wenn ein gebiet als hotspot gilt wann
dem so ist ist im gesetzentwurf bisher
nicht definiert
und in berlin begrüße ich den
bundesgesundheitsminister guten abend
herr lauterbach
hallo
die korona lage ist deutlich schlechter
als die stimmung im land haben sie in
dieser woche selber gesagt wenn dem so
ist müssen sie mit dem neuen
infektionsschutzgesetz todunglücklich
sein hand aufs herz
das infektionsschutzgesetz was wir jetzt
machen verhindert zunächst einmal dass
die maßnahmen komplett auslaufen hätten
wir kein gesetz gemacht wäre am montag
im wahrsten sinne des wortes der frieden
die eingetretenen letztes gar keine
schutzmaßnahmen mehr gegeben wir haben
uns jetzt darauf geeinigt dass dort wo
die fallzahlen hoch sind oder wo sich
stark steigen und wo die
hospitalisierung also einen gerade
erreicht hat dass die versorgung
gefährdet ist das dort zusätzliche
maßnahmen möglich sind also zum beispiel
masken dass dort hygiene konzepte
umgesetzt werden kann 2g zweig plus
geprüft werden kann abstände bewahrt
werden somit ist das instrumentarium was
wir kennen überall dort wo hohe
fallzahlen sind tatsächlich auch möglich
und das hatte ich schon für sehr wichtig
und trotzdem mal lauter was hinter fast
alle bundesländer todunglücklich mit
diesem gesetz das wurde heute auch in
der mpk mehr als deutlich eben weil
jetzt ab sonntag etliche schutzregeln
wegfallen unter anderem die masten
pflicht an schulen und in geschäften die
gewirkt haben also setzten sie in der
opposition
sie würden das vermutlich
unverantwortlich nennen
bleiben wir doch eine sekunde bei den
fakten und nicht bei dem narrativ die
fakten sind aus dort wo die fallzahlen
hoch sind oder steigen und die
krankenhaus belastung gefährdet ist da
können auch masken in den schulen
beispielsweise vorausgesetzt werden oder
also die masken in den geschäften und
das wird für die übergangsphase sowieso
in ganz deutschland der fall sein somit
glaube ich wird es hier etwas schwerer
für die länder weil die landtage jetzt
plötzlich diese maßnahmen beschließen
müssen sie kommen nicht mehr automatisch
durch einen beschluss vom bund die
landtage müssen was machen ich glaube
aber dass das gesetz wirken würden dass
sich die aufregung über das gesetz sehr
schnell legen wird wenn man sieht wie es
angewendet wird mecklenburg vorpommern
plant ja offenbar das gesamte land durch
eine solche hotspot regelungen
abzudecken sie sagen dass ein hotspot
sind stärkere restriktionen möglich aber
ab wann genau welche grenzwerte
überschritten sein müssen da bleibt ihr
gesetz doch recht vage warum nicht
konkrete
es kommt ja immer auf die jeweilige
variante ansagen einmal im gesetz hätte
jetzt an den grenzwert gestanden von
einer inzidenz von marnette wegen 200
dann wäre dieser wert für eine data
variante viel zu hoch gewesen aber für
die omikron variante wäre er zu niedrig
gewesen und wenn sie ein gesetz machen
wo sie für jede einzelne variante zum
beispiel omikron gibt es zwei super baa1
auf ba2 in so ein gesetz machen wo sie
grenzwerte für jede variante also vor
sehen dann kommen sie ein sehr kurzes
gras die gerichte sind gewöhnt dass man
eigentlich erklärt was die gefahrenlage
ist und die gut begründete gefahrenlage
also durch die länder vorgetragen durch
die landtage das hat fast immer bestand
gehabt vor den gerichten das ist auch
die aussage des
bundesministers mit dem ich das gesetz
ja gemacht habe und er sagt das würde so
funktionieren ich kann seine rechtliche
kompetenz nicht anzweifeln und habe auch
keinen grund dafür
gut und ist das neue
infektionsschutzgesetz bis zum 23
september befristet wenn sich die lage
bis dahin weiter verschlimmerte kommt
dann nach der parlamentarischen
sommerpause gleich das nächste wieder
schärfere gesetz
dann kam das jahr folge sogar noch
früher stellen wir uns vor dass
folgendes passiert das ist ermöglicht
dass die amica und variante die jetzt
hoch ansteckendes dass die auch noch
gefährlicher werde die tatsache dass die
variante nicht ganz so gefährlich ist
das hängt an ein paar mutationen die
können verloren gehen dann hätten wir
plötzlich eine situation omikron so
gefährlich wie data und so ansteckend
die omikron dann müssten wir natürlich
sofort reagieren das heißt dieses gesetz
ist für die jetzige situation zunächst
einmal zurecht gearbeitet und das ist
auch korrekt zu aber wenn die die sich
verändert dann würden wir sofort
herangehen und würden das gesetz
überarbeiten also viele experten trauen
sich ja keine prognose mehr zu für den
sommer und den herbst eben weil sie
nicht wissen in welchem umfang auch
gelockert wird ich frage sie mal als
wissenschaftler was kommt da
möglicherweise noch auf uns zu
ich glaube dass hier im sommer
fallzahlen haben werden höher als im
letzten jahr wir werden also nicht so
eine situation haben dass wir eine ganz
niedrige incident und somit einen
sorgenfrei und sommer hatten das wird
nicht so sein dafür dass omikron zu
ansteckend und im herbst kommt es
einfach darauf an dass also gefährlich
so wäre wenn wirklich promikon
gefährlicher würde also so ansteckend
wie jetzt aber einfach gefährlicher die
data variante kann zurückkommen das kann
sich aber auch eine kombination zwischen
theater und annika und entwickeln
christian drosten hat dazu sehr gute
arbeiten vorgelegt an denen orientiere
ich mich auch ein bisschen und das ist
wertvolle arbeit man kann daher den
herbst schlecht vorhersagen aber eines
ist ganz ganz ganz sicher das kann ich
hier verbindlich sagen ohne eine
allgemeine impfpflicht werden wir im
herbst große probleme haben und daran
werden wir auch die politik messen herr
lauterbach danke für diese auskünfte
berlin
ich danke ihnen
es wird alles zerstört was uns lieb und
teuer ist hat präsident talents gehe in
seiner ansprache an den bundestag heute
gesagt das relativiert manches was uns
in der pandemie so zerstörerisch
vorgekommen ist trotzdem beides kann
nicht wirklich verglichen werden aber
eines haben diese ausnahmezustände
gemeinsam nur mit empathie und mit
solidarität können sie bewältigt werden
das war unser zdf spezial danke für ihr
interesse und auf wiedersehen
[Musik]